but first protestors took to the streets
in downtown Las Vegas tonight as well
what started as a peaceful protests
turned into violence very quickly three
hours in we can see there's a lot of
tension out there right now one of those
on the receiving end of that was our
reporters we start our team coverage
tonight we have Orko manna and Bianca
Holman out on the front lines but first
let's touch base with Orko Orko their
reports that Metro Police deployed tear
gas as tensions rose what can you tell
us well Sasha I along with some other
members of our 8 News Now team were in
that crowd when we were hit with some
kind of tear gas or pepper spray I can
tell you from firsthand experience it
was really difficult to see hard to
breathe and this all went down here near
Fremont and 7th Street it has since
cleared out but you can still see all of
the debris in the ground you can also
see some police officers over there
again much calmer but tensions were very
high here earlier between protesters and
police now here is video of what we when
witness firsthand metro police officers
in tactical gear toward a line on the
street pushing protesters back some
protests some protesters started
throwing water bottles at the police
we saw officers put on their face masks
and then throw what seemed to be again
teargas or pepper spray into the crowd
people immediately started running away
dispersing through the different side
streets and alleys my photographer and I
also moved away from the scene it was
very hard to see again since the gas got
into our eyes but we were able to find a
nearby empty parking lot again back out
here live the protesters earlier excuse
me for that we apologize for that the
evening started to peacefully protest
but again as you saw it looks like there
is some issue going on out there we do
apologize for that profanity it's hard
to control in situations like that now
these protests wound their way through
our downtown streets at different times
groups split off and went in different
directions 8 News and our reporter
Bianca Holman was with protesters all
night as well so Bianca described the
scene where you are and it was time at
times very chaotic as well
yes Asha we were in that same vicinity
where Orca was as he just described
myself and my photographer we were there
also we're still recovering from that
tear gas and pepper spray very intense
moments but leading up to that as the
protestors came here in their city hall
they circled back over to container park
and so for a while there there was
people playing music people still just
you know saying black lives matter and
in various chants that we've heard
throughout the past couple of days but
then the confusion came when we were at
eighth in Fremont 8th and between 7th
and 8th on Friedman Street and that was
there there were some times at times
where they were saying hey we're gonna
split off we're gonna come back over to
the courthouse but there were many
people who were they were saying hey if
you're gonna hold the line if you're
gonna be here then you know stay here we
need people to stay here and kind of
face off with police but that's Orko
described there were a select few who
threw bottles who threw things into the
police office where the police officers
are standing which is what prompted you
know some of the the tear gas that was
dispersed and from the officers also
after that where we were in that parking
lot we did observe a man being detained
by police and there was also legal
observers there have been legal
observers out there with the protesters
yesterday on free on the Las Vegas
Boulevard and here tonight they were
wearing red shirts and they're there to
offer legal aid to the anybody who is
detained by police and so they'll get
the names of that person who's detained
they'll also get the name of the officer
and be able to help them get out of jail
if possible the next day so right now
there's still several police officers at
various intersections still a couple of
people walking around but for the most
part large groups have been dispersed so
we're gonna send it back to you in the
studio
Sasha the